we're out ofsyrup huh you know what maybe I'll use my intern glootie good thanks
glootie anything else do you want to
develop a nap no thanks glootie hey
what's up glootie hi Morty do you want to
develop no thanks Rick what does it say
do not develop my app on your interns
forehead why you want to develop one I'm
glad you asked that Jerry it's so you
don't develop his app glootie go make
some photocopies of something cool well
if anyone wants to develop without with
me I'm down he seems to really want to
develop a no sweetie but nobody's going to
do that
okay cloody take the app down kind of
take it down
it's your rat I'm just an intent that's
not how apps work you think we're stupid
but we're not we know apps have
something to do with servers the service
on the mothership where's the mothership
it's coming take us to it yes shake it
more Morty that was working take us to
the mothership okay okay don't hit me an
ominous beeping app you can't stay mad
at a guy with this kind of talent dad
you can and you have to hey what's up
guys what's up guys
and season four it's the forest of all
seasons cuz it's the fourth one it's a
lot different from season three we've
got a lot of a lot of shoot-'em-ups a
lot of laser shoot-'em-ups and crystals
little monster I thought you were
masturbating you took that in stride
there are old faces coming back for a
little bit more of that old stuff that
they did the reason the you're getting
five and then a small break and then the
back five is because Turner Broadcasting
warned us about entertainment signal
levels we had all ten ready to go but we
had to legally cut it back to just five
we did some focused test screenings we
showed all ten episodes to a housewife
from Salt Lake City and her balls blew
off like after episode three it was just
too much we upped it by two episodes for
the skateboard crowd because they're
more extreme they drink Mountain Dew
it's really because if you watch them
all together in a row it's they're so
good it has a high effect on your deep
cellular tissue
Rick and Morty could actually literally
blow your balls off we missed all of our
deadlines welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this is going to be my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 2 video they
dropped a new preview so if you're new
to my channel I'll be doing videos for
all the episodes this season be sure to
subscribe to get everything we're also
doing a weekly merch giveaway - the
title of the episode the old man in the
seat is a reference to Ernest
Hemingway's story the Old Man and the
sea so it's probably a little bit about
Rick because he is the old man literally
in the episode but also Jerry if you
think about what the actual story of the
old man of the sea is about it's all
about this old man's long battle to try
and catch this giant fish thinking that
it will bring him this measure of
success in
Fame and he'll finally be able to rest
so Rick in this episode seems like he
wants to rest he doesn't want to do any
of these menial tasks anymore
so when sort of reference to the butter
robot what is my purpose to pass the
butter oh my god so he hires himself an
intern from this species whose whole
thing is they use apps or develop apps
to take over planets the way that Dan
and Justin talked about and though the
glooty character played by Ty Cobb YTD
from thor ragnarok if you didn't
recognize his voice Korg
is playing glooty is that what Rick
really wants is a slave to do really
crappy tasks and normally he would just
get Morty to do that but because of the
way the power dynamic is shifted in the
family he can't get him to do that
anymore
because Beth who's now the head of the
household again won't let him do that
dad there's a way we do this now but
somatically the old man of the seat is
also Jerry someone who's seen all this
failure and just looking for this one
great success so the people will finally
celebrate him in thinking that it's
going to come from this app that
he's going to develop and make all this
money off of it'll make me famous but as
you would expect Rick knows all about
what's going to happen if you actually
develop his app so that's why he tattoos
that on glue Dee's forehead do not
develop my app but a lot of the comedy
of the episode especially them
developing this app seems like it relies
on Rick not telling them what's going to
happen if they develop the app he just
tells them not to do it which for
someone like Jerry is probably the worst
thing you could do for him he sort of
has the mind of a child when you tell
him not to do something he's immediately
going to do that thing the funnier part
of this cold-open too is that even Morty
who bachas adventures left in right even
during episode one the writers said that
they were making fun of Morty when he
got his crystal and went all Akira they
said that they made the character super
derivative which is exactly what Rick
doesn't want to be he wants to do new
things all the time and throughout the
episode all the different Morty's even
fascist Morty says they want to do
everything that they used to do go back
to a classic Rick and Morty adventure
okay
he was an inferior Rick he was too
political I want to have fun classic
Rick and Morty adventures like in the
old days that's why Morty with the
crystal uses all those meeseeks boxes
just a completely derivative joke going
back to the meeseeks episode in season
one a lot of you also picked up on the
idea that the writers were kind of
making fun of the fandom using those
Morty characters saying that the fandom
keeps asking for classic Rick and Morty
go back to the way you used to do things
but even during this episode Morty is
smart enough to know not to develop the
app so that's how dumb jerry is this
week but you cut to that other scene
later in the episode and it seems like
Morty somehow gets roped in with jerry
developing what seems like an alien
rip-off of tinder maybe it's just an
episode with a Jerry and Morty adventure
because there were some be stories
during season three with Morty's summer
and Jerry where they got some minor
adventures together they just seems like
the next logical step like them actually
going on something that winds up being
the a story up to this spaceship the
whole thing seems like it turns into a
reference from Hitchhiker's Guide with
all the alien bureaucracy this alien app
developing species mimicking some of the
ridiculous bureaucracy that they parody
during Hitchhiker's Guide that's for
sure there's all kinds of Easter eggs
and Jerry's den - there's the golf
poster which is a reference to meeseeks
and destroy' during season one when
Jerry was trying to learn how to golf
there's the poster of the Titanic from
the Titanic episode I'm sure in the
episode if you spin the camera around a
little bit in this room you'll also see
his coin collection
then there's the clip of them talking
about the rest of the season just joking
about the five episodes during 2019
there will actually be another block of
five episodes early next year after the
holidays but they haven't said when
that's actually going to happen right
now my expectation is that'll be
sometime towards the end of January it
won't be that big of a break I'm not
sure why the network though is making
such a big deal about these first five
episodes but it might have something to
do with the way they handle the blu-ray
releases in an effort to syndicate
episodes on other platforms more quickly
which just helps the network earn more
extra money on the episodes faster they
could also be releasing future seasons
like this going forward with two
different blocks of episodes instead of
just ten weeks of episodes and Dan
Harmon is kind of joking but not joking
when he's talking about entertainment
signal levels Turner Broadcasting warned
us about
tainment signal levels they're just a
marketing concept that if you release
too much content the network won't be
able to optimize it quite as much and
earn as much money on it as if they
release smaller blocks of episodes they
kind of do that with younger groups of
kids on Cartoon Network which is the
parent network of Adult Swim that's kind
of why they started to do their weird
release schedules for Adventure Time and Steven universe two really popular shows
but they would just release really weird
seemingly random walks of episodes
instead of just releasing the episodes
like a normal season would if you follow
Dan Harmon on Instagram he also post
pictures from the Rick and Morty writers
room while they're working on season
five episodes portal combat here
actually does sound kind of like a Rick
versus The Citadel of Rick's episode
with them just going after each other
like season 1 episode 10 sometimes it's
hard to tell if they're serious about
some of these ideas though like lady
with ice cream lips
Morty team's up with Captain Crunch some
of the other gems that they had from
this box include artificial person with
a real leg Rick discovers the 11th
commandment as in the 10th commandments
from the Bible Maximum Overdrive but
with grass planet of no stop signs
trench coat made of dreams the people's
basketball court
Wesley sniper when wolf instead of
werewolf Voltron but with vegetables
that actually sounds like a follow up
idea to pickle Rick when you watched
episode 1 if you slowed the episode down
and saw the crystal when it showed all
the different ways that they might die
pickle Rick was in one of those deaths
implying that there was some other
reality or some future where Rick
pickles himself again library of food a
lot of food based ideas maybe they were
just really hungry and they were getting
ready to eat lunch when they were
working on these ideas Jerry gets a pine
cone in his that just sounds awful
detachable fingers or toes beads I
don't know what's going on with that
idea or how they try to get that past
broadcast standards planet powered by
chips and salsa
another lunch idea Morty buys a boat
bark NATO planet of the Hodags bloodshed
invisible pigs and Jerry makes a log
cabin with hair but let me know in the
comments which of these ridiculous be
story ideas is your favorite and what
will happen is is I'll post my full
season 4 episode 2 Easter Egg video
Monday morning so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see the video when I post
I'll name a new giveaway winner when I
post that so while you wait for
everything click here for my season 4
episode 1 video and click here for my
new Star Wars Mandalorian episode 2
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight!